is the great reset a good thing no why
not because the people who are
controlling it are doing it with
nefarious purposes so i'm not i'm not
against the idea of a societal reset so
to speak a changing of the paradigm or
whatever i agree with michael malus
national divorce some people would call
that a reset but you know when we talk
about the whole buildback better un
agenda whatever if you're into alex
jones i mean that's referring to a
specific number and group of people with
a specific agenda the great reset is
real the world economic forum has
proposed it they're very woke the davos
group wants these things to happen these
people are very much concerned about
climate change and very much so they
want people to stop consuming to eat the
bugs and to live in vance yeah so this
is this is the interesting thing about
the great reset i see a lot of people
say i will not eat the bugs i will not
live in the pod i'll eat the bugs i
won't live in the potty yeah there you
go oh i'm okay with the bugs i'll eat
the bugs and live in the pot
i'm i'm if you choose the pod
yeah no i mean i think about like i'd
i'd love to just have like a a tiny
house like by a river or go fishing and
just and you know be responsible for
myself and uh i have no issue with
eating bugs other than they have to be
farmed properly and not really parasites
so don't eat bugs off the ground the
media telling people to eat bug that's
the craziest thing we bought cricket
powder oh that's the uh the the camera
they're not plugged in yeah okay let me
see if i can play it let me see if i can
do it you guys thanks continue our
conversation so this is now the uh
lauren chen show that's right she's
taking over okay lauren if you had to
eat a bug what would your favorite bug
be it would be something crunchy i've
thought about this before because i used
to watch do you guys know bear grylls
right he's that adventure guy huge fan
of his and i've watched a lot of shows
and i feel like you you want to go
crunchy not slimy it stopped beeping
and i also don't get why so many people
when they do like bug eating challenges
or they talk about it they don't cook
the buck i would cook them like just
treat it like regular food yeah cook it
clean it like prepare
yeah how would you cook it would you add
i mean in china they and like thailand
they do like a deep fry thing with bugs
my dad he's had like deep-fried
silkworms and i mean that's like a slimy
thing so i still wouldn't want to do it
but i feel like you could make bugs
palatable oh i'm sure yeah we got
cricket powder yeah tim just got a bunch
of it actually i'll try it i'll try to
make some bread with it we're gonna make
cricket bread
it's gonna be a mix because there's not
enough powder to make a big five five
cup loaf and there's no gluten in it
it's just it's just gritty ground up
like a gluten make it sticky yeah
so but we have the high high high gluten
flour so we'll just do a little bit make
it maybe help bond or something
you can make cookies really easily
because you don't need a lot of cricket
cookies yeah there's a bunch of recipes
for that i tried like a gluten-free
muffin one time and it was like a
dandelion like you know you blow and
just like crumbles in the air because
yeah
you want the gluten if you can have it i
got no problem being bugs
i i i just think when i see the media
it's really creepy
when all of these news outlets pop up
with the same story like go eat the
cicadas and it's like no no no no did
you guys see the story about the dude
who ate the slug and then got paralyzed
and then died no no rugby player oh
don't eat bugs off the ground man
it's like if you want people are like
you can't eat
there's an article from nbc said don't
hug you and kiss your chickens
and i'm like yeah no dog it's okay to
eat the cicadas right what that's the
craziest thing they're like if you hug
and kiss your chickens you could get
salmonella or whatever and i'm like dude
we have chickens yeah i will pet them
and then i go and i wash yeah yeah well
i think the issue is a lot of people
conflate nature with safe and healthy
which if you've spent any number like
amount of time in nature you know it's
not the case yeah i mean yeah i mean i
think people live in this idea we're
like yeah you can just like go into the
forest eat whatever drink from a stream
and it's like no you can't do that you
will die very quickly if you try this
this is the weirdest thing there's a lot
of there's a lot of contradictory things
i see in in the culture war right you
would think the conservatives would be
the ones saying to eat the bugs and live
in the pods you know why it's like
hardier survival yeah it's it's tougher
it's more self-reliant it's
it's it's stronger like the way i look
at it
eating bugs i'm like dude i'll eat i'll
do what i have to do to survive me too i
would do well in the apocalypse i'll eat
anything i'm scrappy yeah exactly grass
so i'm sure you can eat grass you got to
boil it
you can season it you can fatigue
you can boil grass there's some stuff in
it but a human will not get enough
energy out of it so it's if you have to
you can maybe make a supplement yeah
it's like even with the same with uh
rabbits i think there's not enough fat
on them right so it's like sailing yeah
they used to they would know okay well
we need some we need some fat shouldn't
conservatives be the ones who are like
if i had to i will live in the i will
live in a pod not like a government
mandated pod they shove you in but like
you build your own hut in the middle of
the world what's the thing i think a lot
of conservatives do have the equivalent
of bug out pods and they probably do
have like the mres which make you know
you know survival food which maybe has
bug bug in it probably but i think the
idea is that like they don't think it's
necessary and there are these
big government people who are telling
you to live in a pod so they can live in
excess right yeah you know there's a
meme it's really funny they were like
it's a liberal saying we've got 10 years
until climate change destroys the world
and the conservative says so what are
you doing about it and they're like
getting an arts degree living in a big
city and not preparing and trying to get
guns banned yeah it's like you certainly
don't think the end is nigh you're
saying that i don't know if i believe
you that's that's the funniest thing
it's like
i'm sorry i would never take the bet if
there was a liberal and a conservative
and it was like okay we're gonna put
them both in the woods who survives i'm
like
every every hour of the day every day of
the week i'm betting on the conservative
to survive even if it's like a 55 year
old big pot belly you know old
conservative guy with a confederate flag
shirt i'd be like i still think he's
going to win that guy's going to know
how to grow possum man you get the
liberal guy is going to write a book out
of barker so you get the occasional
hippie that eats like
grubs
that doesn't eat very much and it's
super skinny that guy's usually pretty
liberal comes from like eating seeds
yeah yeah doesn't need much energy to
survive so to be fair
the leftists
will uh the average leftist will
probably starve because there's going to
try and take food from each other
a certain sect of libertarian leftists
will do just fine because they're
probably just sitting you know playing
their guitar like stoned anyway and
they're sharing just eating what they
can eating grubs and bugs then the
conservatives are you know chopping down
the trees out there well i think a big
difference between who would and would
not survive that also intersects
politically is urban versus rural yeah
right and that's a big divide
politically urban people tend to be
overwhelmingly leftists and i mean you
can tell in their policies if you if you
look at how you know they are concerned
for things like overpopulation and
climate change and just pollution in
general i'm not saying that those aren't
concerns but i think just looking at the
environments that they live in cities
that are dirty and overcrowded if you go
to the country i think you're much more
likely to feel like you are kind of
living closer to nature and you're just
frankly more likely to have those
survival skills i mean you have city
people who probably
i don't know have never been camping
never made a fire by themselves of
course if
if the shiz hit the fan they wouldn't
survive that is fascinating to think
that the people that live in cities are
obsessed with climate change because
they're breathing in brake dust and
they're causing it yeah and they're
they're affected by it like people in
the country aren't affected by it yep
so they don't think about it the
pollution in in some of these chinese
cities it's just it's nuts where they're
like the big tv screen that looks like
sunlight because it's all smog los
angeles smog problem what san francisco
has a small no they have a poop problem
the people who live in these areas are
like look at all these problems like bro
stop living in a concrete cubicle in a
city that's covered in poop yeah and
it's i mean it's the same thing with
their concerns about things like wealth
and equality and stuff like that the the
people who are most concerned with
wealth inequality come from l.a and new
york and that's because they are living
in the places with the millionaires and
the homeless people like if you go to
the rest of the country not to say there
aren't still rich and poor people but
it's a lot more equitable it's just
these people in these like urban coastal
centers they think their little bubble
is representative of the entire country
peaceful divorce yes we can all of these
cities should be free and independent
and they can form in city states
yeah well actually so
one of my friends he he was saying that
he's from california he doesn't want to
give up california but so his his
solution was not like full succession
but it's like there can be like little
city-state protectorates within the
greater america and they can have like
they could pay
for uh utilities and like national
defense they did collapse in two seconds
yeah because they survive off stealing
resources la only la uh i shouldn't say
only exist but mostly exist because
they're getting the colorado river water
and if at any point like their
jurisdictions to the east of l.a they
could just be like nope shut it off yes
city-states seem to fall apart with the
invention of gunpowder i don't know
exactly when they started fading away
but i mean the vatican i think still is
a city state well even you have the uae
the united arab emirates with like dubai
and abu dhabi i mean i'm not super well
versed on how they're doing but i think
in essence they operate similarly to
that it used to be walls would protect
the giant citadel and you couldn't get
in but then the gunpowder you could
break down the walls then of course air
power well fun fact um quebec city in
canada is like the only walled city in
north america really yeah wow it's like
walden
but not the entire city i can't um i
mean at one point it used to be i don't
know if it is all still up but i we went
there for my birthday a couple years ago
wall street in new york was a big joke
yeah i was the big one back in the day
yeah so i want to go back to this point
uh about you know climate change and
survival and stuff because
when i think about we we just talked a
lot about liberals not being able to
survive the wilderness which is mostly
the truth there's probably some liberals
who you know know what they're doing you
seem to make it in a fred
what's that oh it's a show where they
take two people and get them naked and
then drop them in the woods really it's
crazy yeah you get the occasional
liberal dude that just doesn't eat very
much
well i've i've heard people talk about
shows like that and like they've put
vegans on and they end up having to eat
a bug or something just because like
it's easy it's fast you need the protein
did you ever did you ever see that one
show where they have two islands one
with only men one with only women no and
then like the women start fighting with
each other and they can't get anything
done like one expedition group gets lost
and starts panicking because they can't
find their way back and then like
meanwhile on the dude island they have
like their own bars already built and
they're like distilling alcohol coconuts
yeah and then the women come to the
men's island start saying like give us
stuff and give us resources well that's
like i have this evolutionary theory
that is backed up by nothing
my opinion but um have you noticed that
women don't work well together generally
there's like the whole queen beat lydia
probably knows yes i work you know
yeah and i think the reason why that is
is because men have an evolutionary
drive to work together for things like
hunting but if you look at traditionally
like back way back before we had like
societies women did not really have much
incentive to partner with other women
right because your your child rearing
was usually your own family members
other females you wouldn't
share those responsibilities with
females who weren't related to you
whereas if you were a man you would go
hunting with all the other village men
it's not the same for women that's a
good point yes so the woman was looking
towards the the man who was going to
kill the bear and you know bring the
food back and the man was looking for
people who could partner with him to go
and bring the food back right and
actually if evolutionary speaking if
you're a woman you do have an incentive
to view all other women as competitors
for
your man and his chunk of bear meat i i
agree but from my understanding women
tend to be more bisexual than men
because they had to cooperate with other
women because of polygamy
you'd have more than one wife so you
needed to cooperate with other women so
i don't know you go either way on that
one but you're probably right yeah i
don't know like like i said this is not
based on science like at all it's just
my opinion
it's weird how that manifests in modern
politics so it makes me it reminds me of
people have mentioned the the rat utopia
experiment i think it was was a mouse
utopia yeah yeah they gave they they
created a utopia where the where the
mice were free to just do whatever they
wanted unlimited food and you know but a
finite space and then eventually they
reached this population maximum where
they stopped reproducing they started
becoming more you know homosexual or
like atypical so like san francisco i
maybe
i mean maybe these things are emerging
society because we've reached the
epitome of wealth and survival yeah that
there's so i mean if you think about it
there were reactions to deviations from
social norms that were very severe like
women who worked were witches and did
meth because women needed to have babies
otherwise you were on the verge of
collapse now we have so much
that
we don't need everybody to be having
families technically like humanity's not
going to go extinct
because people aren't having babies in
fact it's the other way around or even
within your own family you no longer
need to have seven in the hopes that
like three or four make it to adulthood
you can pretty much be guaranteed that
they're all going to survive so now
there's no threat to society for
deviations of social norms so people
stopped caring yeah and this is this is
another point i've heard i don't know i
don't know to the extent of which it's
factually cracked ask historian when i
was reading about the end of slavery
notably in the uk it started there
because of industrialization it wasn't
this great moral awakening of these
european you know countries it was you
didn't need it it was it was actually
cheaper to get the machine to do it yeah
and so then all of a sudden they were
like people stopped supporting it
because it wasn't benefiting them as
much anymore and as the support faded
they just said okay we're done with it i
think the uk just paid like they they
paid the people who had slaves that's
okay we're done in the u.s though it was
very different because it's a very very
large country trying to enforce laws
across the whole country in the northern
areas that were industrializing they
were like nobody really needs it anymore
so then they start voting against it in
the southern states where it was less
developed they were demanding the right
to keep slaves so the point i'm trying
to make is don't don't give people
credit for having a great moral
awakening it was just as soon as it
doesn't benefit people anymore then all
of a sudden they're willing to let go
because there's better paths towards
wealth it's kind of creepy think about
it the way humans are yeah i mean and
also we were talking about democracy and
like now that we bring up slavery that
is one of the other reasons why i don't
think democracy is a good way to judge a
society's morality i mean if you look at
where most of people most of society's
moral compass would have been during the
slavery era most people were white most
people were fine with it does that mean
that it was therefore moral for people
to keep slaves i mean right because they
were the minority and everyone else
thought it was fine no it does not yeah
not not cool
but it's uh
so many different cultures have
functioned in basically the same way
it's like a human universal i think
people
i'm i'm fairly uh i don't want to say
i'm optimistic or personal it's not a
very nihilistic or neutral when it comes
to trusting humans intentions
i think people are very self-interested
yeah yes i think they can have empathy
but i think
like learning about that that's one of
the biggest drivers of ending slavery
was just they were making money doing
other things so it was not
it was not caring it was a lack of
caring all of a sudden they weren't
threatened to lose their slaves and they
were making money doing other things so
they said i don't care whatever do
whatever you want it was probably a risk
to hold slaves you know if you could
have a machine that did it for you or
you could have slaves that might end up
murdering you or running away and
causing violence
so there's less of a threat you know
analogy the humans change evolution as a
result of necessity for the most part
not because it's morally just it's just
how it's pretty much been throughout the
ages well i mean interesting addition to
this conversation that could also apply
to automation now right i mean it's the
same thing with your cashier that you
see at the checkout of a grocery store
or at a restaurant that's why a lot of
people are saying just like maybe they
did slavery industrialization it's
cheaper to automate so now you no longer
have a lot of those like hourly workers
you just have your little self-service
scan thing or kiosk where you put in the
order
yeah nobody wants the work but it's more
than just the kiosks it's a lot of other
the the big problem there is we're not
talking about forced labor we're talking
about parts of the economy that are
being
automated and then people don't have
work
can't get money this i think is one of
the reasons we see the rise of
socialists this problem emerges where
people through no real fault of their
own there's a lot of people who don't
want to work it's their fault there's a
lot of people who got automated out of
the workplace and then where they get
told learn to code not automated or even
just technology displace them and they
get told learn to code and it going to
work so what do you do well we can't
just be luddites and they're like okay
we're banning technology because people
need jobs that's stupid it's supposed to
make things easier but here's the
problem
if we start giving these people money
like ubi
what do you tell the farmer
who has to work right well they the the
people who live in the cities it's it's
this way right now people in new york
well at least before the pandemic
working for media companies are getting
paid thirty forty fifty thousand dollars
to write garbage trash articles about
nonsense meanwhile people are getting
paid minimum wage to pick fruit on a
farm
so how does that make sense
by the left's own standard they should
not be getting that level of pay for
what they do
that's going to be a big problem when we
start when we when we create ubi or if
andrew yang gets his way in new york
city and tries doing some kind of ubi
you mean you're going to have someone
who lives in new york city of all places
one of the wealthiest places on the
planet
getting free money to buy the apples
that i pick for dirt wages
i'll just move to new york city get free
money yeah why bother yeah i don't like
the job economy thing the the federal
reserve's obsessed with creating job
creating employment for everyone they
want you to dig a hole and they want you
to fill the hole back up and then
they're going to loan you money
for it and then expect you to pay pay
them back with interest so they keep
everyone busy and you can see as we're
automating that that doesn't work people
don't have things to do and creating you
know random things that don't benefit
society doesn't solve that problem well
i think we we saw a lot of that kind of
rhetoric from joe biden's recent like
joint session speech the state of the
union which we're not calling the state
of the union but anyway the idea that
yeah the government would just make jobs
for people to have jobs but i think the
whole problem ultimately is that labor
is and is not
a commodity right it's a commodity in
that it responds to supply and demand
but it's not a commodity in the you know
if you have too many widgets sitting on
the shelves
you just stop producing widgets for a
while and then eventually you'll sell
the ones that were overstocked that's
not true with labor you have
unemployment people get restless they
need to be fed and things like that and
they're right and they riot so i think
the problem why this automation is
happening at the rated is it's a people
are campaigning for high minimum wages
which just makes automation cheaper and
then b you also have an immigration
system that is welcoming in
low-skilled workers who are competing
for jobs that really the people who have
those jobs are already in an extremely
vulnerable position so it's just a bad a
bad situation all around maybe we just
need you know an individual of of of
intelligence and merit to just rise up
naturally and gain power through the
competitive system maybe somebody who
understands like computers because of
like you know someone who's like a
computer developer of some sort
and then he can start deciding what's
best for us yeah like a technocrat like
a technical kid by the way maybe like a
like a dictator oh yeah like a like an
artificial intel no more like bill gates
bill gates did i say that already like
bill gates
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you